[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade washaw Ramy
personality is my co-host today open
phones here at
88255 225 as we talk about you right in
front of you Wayne starts off this hour
in Canada hi Wayne how are you I'm doing
great Dave thank you for taking my call
how you doing today better than I
deserve what's
up oh Dave a little bit nervous here but
we're going to get it out anyways um we
had purchased uh two vac well actually
one vacant lot um again just a vacant
lot Lake Side beautiful property um I
ended up subdividing it uh putting it
splitting it putting in the market it's
going to come on two years probably
October and this month sorry um not
quite two years and again we've had a
little bit of an issue with that
property being on the east coast of
course we've had a hurricane then we had
a fire then we had another hurricane
then we have interest rates and uh we're
struggling nothing's moving of course in
the market there and and where I am too
also as well um we do have a loan on
that property
and um again we're just paying the
interest only on it and I just again I
we have an appointment with our
accountant but our accountant isn't a
real estate person and then our real
estate person isn't a money person like
yourself Dave so I would just like some
advice on that um I could give you uh
kind of a rundown what we have Wayne
you're in the perfect place I'm an
expert on my
opinion oh
all right so uh what's the what how many
Lots did you end up with
subdivided uh one lot was 5.2 uh acres
and the other one is 7.2 Acres so two
lots so you bought a 12 acre track to
split it that's right okay and um what
are you asking for the Lots so the one
lot we plan on keeping the other lot we
are asking 959 for it are you keeping
the larger one or the smaller one we're
keeping the larger one well I would all
right and the it's a lake lot after all
and so and you got enough buffer there
to keep the neighbors off of you Life's
good so uh not what do you owe on
it uh 700 okay and uh do you have
700,000 in cash and
Investments yes I can give you a rundown
if You' like yes please so combined my
wife and I we have $2.2 million in
Investments we have uh700 ,000 and two
other vacant properties that are in our
hometown we have uh a mortgage of 500k
on our uh primary residence which is
worth
1.2 and we have no debt we both have our
emergency funds what's your household
income um combined household income
would be about 425 oh cool and how old
are you
two um I'm 59 n and a half and my wife
is turning
47 well you guys are amazing well done I
mean you you're you're worth three plus
million doll
congratulations approaching $4 million
net worth well done at 59 years old ding
ding a score you're you're not bankrupt
you make 425,000 a year you can survive
this so this is a
philosophical money discussion almost
meaning that you have enough money that
you really can't screw this up either
way you follow me correct I mean you can
ride it out and sit on it and pay the
interest and someday it'll sell or you
could cash out enough to pay off your
house and pay off the lot be 100% debt
free and be $1.2 million less in
Investments but now you've transferred
your investments into your personal
residence and into some lake lots and
that way you're not a motivated seller
anymore cuz you almost sound like you're
emotionally motivated and I want let me
tell you there's only one time you make
money in real estate and that's when you
sell
it correct so when you sell it you
cannot be a motivated seller and
sometimes you can be motivated by
finances but other times you can be
motivated by
disgust like three hurricanes of fire
and interest rates H correct like crap
my plan to clear this lot by splitting
this off and selling the other one was
such a good plan crap that's that's a
motivation seller you follow me yes Am I
Wrong nope
okay I I think the way you make money in
real estate is you chill and the best
way chill is just reach over and pay
that sucker off and while I'm at it I'm
going to go and pay my house off was the
plan weighing for you to sell those two
vacant properties to grab the 700,000 so
you can buy the the attractive land that
you want to keep no when he sells off
the other lot um it sells for 900 yeah
and it's going to pay off the 700 he's
going to clear the first lot but he's
also got two other two tracks they're
just an independent issue you could sell
those if you want to that that would get
him it's not a you might rather have I
mean are they are they going up in value
why are you holding
those um one's right to next door to our
primary residence and I was just we're
just going to give that to our young son
later on or again that was just going to
be just that's a buffer yeah that's a
keeper okay what's the other one the
other one is it's going up in value
because it overlooks the city and
another big lake too so and then um part
of that question was um would you rather
have that or would you rather be and or
would you rather just have le less
liquid cash CU I just use 1.2 of your
2.2 I think I think I think I just
wanted to hear you say what you said and
just going to ride this thing um write
it out because so far to date uh we
spent 72,000 in uh interest right MH and
if we're getting 950 I saying we're
still ahead of the
game the best time to sell something is
when you don't want to or need to
because you get the most for it I mean
you got to have walkway power I'm at a
minimum liquidating enough to pay that
lot
off the 2.2 in Investments is that
retirement Investments or is some of it
non-retirement he's 59 and half oh I
missed that part well there you
go so okay yeah I you shouldn't have any
penalty it means Canada it's different
but you don't have penalties in Canada
at 59 and a half either do
you no that's right no you're correct um
yeah yeah and you've got lots I mean
you've got options you've really just
got to look and see what makes the most
sense for you you can afford to hold it
what would I do if I woke up in your
shoes I'd pay my house off in the lot
off tomorrow yeah and I'd have only a
million dollars left in Investments oh
darn only a million did you hear how
said that only a million doll but I have
not a payment in the world and the lot
that's overlooking the city also goes up
for sale probably if I'm you and I'm
probably not going to I'd probably
rather have the liquid than have that
but uh but I'm getting rid of all the
debt and that just chills you and then
some goober comes along and says okay
you're asking 9.95 but the Market's slow
in hurricanes and interest rates and so
I'm going to offer you 750 which pays
off your loan which they can look up at
the courthouse and tell what your loan
is so which is exactly what I would do
where I bang the from you in a down
Market I try to buy it for what you owe
and get just let you out of the trap to
heck with the
cheese um but instead instead there's no
there's no trap we just got rid of the
Trap that's great I love that great
strategy and so um then you go no we're
not going to take 750 I'll just wait and
I did that not long ago and as soon as
you call someone's Bluff the price goes
up there you go this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's it's a membership based
nonprofit Ministry where hundreds of
thousands of Christians share funds to
pay for and pray for each other's
medical bills for over 40 years chm has
helped families living across all 50
states so see if chm could be right for
your family check out more today at
chministries.org
[Music]
budget
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Sam's in Austin Texas Hi
Sam how are you I'm doing pretty good
how you doing better than I deserve how
can we
help well um you know I'm callin because
you know I've uh over the years we or
the last couple years we bought a house
things seemed to be going okay and then
we ended up getting kind of taxed on the
actual build of the house and that just
kind of started a slippery slope where
we started having to pay more than what
our mortgage originally was and we ended
up relying on a lot of credit cards and
it got really bad and right now we're in
I'm I'm especially in collections for
lot of cards and my wife has a few she
was sued I got a case coming as well and
I I just don't really know where to turn
or how to turn this around it almost
seems kind of
hopeless sorry Sam how much credit card
debt do is is their
total uh probably
around probably 15 to 16,000 and how
much income do you guys bring in every
month uh every month um about
6,000 how much is your house payment
okay how much are your car
payments we only have one car payment
and it's 250 and as far as like the the
mortgage it's uh when we were being
taxed on the Improvement after about a
year of having a lower payment it was
about
2700 and now we're down to I finally
paid off the um the uh overage on the
escrow and um now you know the 2100 is
about normal okay all right and what do
you guys do for
living uh I'm in technical supports and
she works uh in a dental office okay
your mortgage is high your car payment
is all car payments are bad this one's
not super bad um the credit cards are uh
the way you were talking I thought you
were going to tell me you had 100,000 in
credit card debt um the weight the
weight that you're emotionally carrying
listening to your voice um I'm
pleasantly surprised it's only 15 me too
yeah I think the mortgage being a third
of your take-home is really what's and
it was higher than that for a while but
even that where where else do are you
guys just disorganized and you were
living in panic and money's just flying
out of there and you had no idea where
it was
going that's that's a pretty good way to
put it yeah yeah okay because I mean
your numbers aren't as as bad as the
they don't indicate you should even be
behind yeah and and and I agree with you
there CU When I you know when I sit
there and kind of add up numbers and you
know look at it that way I I look at it
I'm like okay how many kids have you got
we have five total oh and how old are
they uh they range from teenagers down
to seven okay how many are in
daycare none they're all in school okay
okay well you and well our old is she
works and um but you know she she just
graduated high school yeah but um and
and the main thing is is that you know I
think what okay H how many credit cards
are you behind
on um
probably I would say it's pretty good
number probably about eight to 10 so
there's a whole bunch of little ones
yeah yeah and you're behind on almost
all of them uh I've got four myself that
I you said two have gone two have gone
to
collections no they're pretty much all
in collections but I have four that I've
made payment arranges with but two of
them um have B lawsuits yeah you said
your wife got sued on one of them right
filed
lawsuits yeah oh that's cute on how
much uh hers is a little bit over 3,000
the same for mine oh man okay let me
just tell you you live in Texas am I got
that right is that the truth that's
correct
okay well their lawsuits useless they
can't garnish e wages or take a lean on
a house in Texas right right so it's
just hanging their lawsuits hanging out
there in The Ether it's just dangling
out there in the nothingness it has
there's nothing they can do about it cuz
with hers we hired a lawyer and they're
working on the
case it was the fear thing at the time
know that's the thing Sam what you like
looking at the numbers that you've given
us maybe there's more debt out there
that you haven't mentioned but I think
that you're way more what you're feeling
is way more emotional than it is
financial it's like oh my gosh I've got
12 credit cards they're suing us you
know the kids are like it's like all
these things going on and if you just
stop for a moment if we really look at
the numbers and look at the math there's
no reason that we can't list these from
smallest to largest cuz like Dave said
most of them are probably lower balances
because there's tons of them and they're
only equaling up to 15 to 16,000 so my
guess is that if you can just kind of
pull all of this out of space get it
down on paper like I said list them
smallest to largest figure out what it
looks like for you guys to get an extra
one to $2,000 in every month and you're
knocking them out like dominoes you're
going to feel so much better how many
cars do you
own um we we have two that we use for
getting the kids around um our oldest
son has his own that he uses for school
and and and you bought it for
him uh it was he's a stepson and his dad
gave it to him as a gift okay all right
yeah it's just a little truck okay I'm
just trying to find out what's going on
here all right so what did this lawyer
tell you he could do that the law has
done for you in Texas they basically
said that no no they just basically said
that they could either get the case
dismiss or work out some type of lower
settlement essentially that's all they
offered okay well the case is not going
to get dismissed you owe the money you
lost right you owe the money you didn't
pay it you lose ding okay now then can
we settle it for Less well sure it's
3,000 bucks they can't collect it in
Texas so of course you can settle it for
Less um and you can do that with all you
can do that with all of these by the way
and next time don't use a lawyer what
did you pay the lawyer a 750 okay I sure
hope he gets 750 off the balance at
least earns his keep I I don't know how
he took your money in good conscience
but um uh all right now the main thing I
I worry about is like uh because I've
heard that you know I understand they
can't Dage my wages but they could like
take it from my bank account not unless
you give them the not unless you give
them access to your bank account well
they lean you can take a lean on it in
Texas that's true well don't keep if you
got a bunch of money in your bank
account I guess we'd pay the bills huh
yeah I mean I really don't at the time
but you at the current moment but you
know working on this here and building
up you know no I'm just saying I'm just
saying the if if there was $10,000 in
your bank account you wouldn't have
called me yeah so you don't have any
money in your bank account so it's not a
big fear yeah okay okay so anyway what
we've got to do is a get organized and
get a very detailed plan and B let's
prioritize first thing is house is paid
our food food then house then lights and
water then car are you behind on the car
no no no okay good stay current on the
car go to work and we're going to get
you on an every dollar budget with Jade
and put you in one of her webinars
when's your next webinar oh gosh it's
not till November I don't know that we
have we'll get you we'll get you plugged
into an every doll webinar so you can
learn how to do a budget with your wife
and uh we'll put you into financial
piece university cuz basically what
we're going to do is we're going to take
care of food shelter clothing
transportation and utilities first you
You' got the money to do that and then
we're going to force rank these things
and work them through and lump some
settlement all of them each smallest to
largest I'm not paying payments on them
anymore I'm going to lump some
settlement you're behind uh the lawsuit
is got no teeth where you live okay okay
so just argue with them and say I'm
broke I owe you
$3,000 uh you say it's 5,000 after you
added a bunch of fees um I have 2,000 if
you'll take that and give me that in
writing that that's a settlement in full
remember that phrase and no electronic
access to your checking account as Jade
said they will never know where your
checking account is but um settlement in
full in writing and then I'll send you
$2,000 oh you won't do that did you know
there's nine other credit cards that
will one of them's going to take the
money I got you on the phone last chance
going once going twice I'm going to the
next card okay second card here's what
we're going to do I just Tong up on the
other guy cuz he's an idiot let's see if
you are all right and we're going to
settle this going once and going twice
and you're going to work your way
through this and then you cycle back
through after you finally get one to
take the money then you pile up a little
more money and you start the whole
process again remember last time I
called you when you didn't take the deal
you sure you don't want to take it cuz
I'm here with another deal and I'm
getting ready to go on to the second one
going once going twice and this is how
you deal with these people cuz credit
card collectors are scum you can tell
they're lying if their mouth is moving
so beat the snot out of them and get
this cleaned up that's what you do this
is the ramsy
[Applause]
[Music]
show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and and gives
you a custom loan built for you based on
your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumpsum payoff option you could qualify
for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Jade washaw Ramsey personality open
phones at
88255 225 thank you for hanging out with
us America Jade is my co-host today and
uh we mentioned you're going to be doing
the every dollar webinars with that last
caller on budgeting your next one is not
till November you said that's couple
weeks away Rachel Cruz is doing them
George camel is doing them if you want
to go to a free everyll budgeting cuz
webinar they're going to show you how to
do this go to everydollar.com
budgeting because Jade when you're um it
sounded like with him with those credit
cards he's got the money to pay them
he's just disorganized and the budget is
literally a way to get organized yeah
that's exactly when you don't have a
plan for your money it just feels like
it's chaos money's going out it's going
in all directions you don't know where
it's going but when you have the piece
of a budget you get to see how every
dollar is being spent and it helps you
identify those problem areas well 100%
of the time that you put your income
that you have for the month at the top
and you start deducting basic
necessities out you will feel like you
got a raise yeah we see that because
you're like where is this money going
and I can't I don't know where it's been
going well it doesn't matter where it's
been going all that matters now is that
it starts going where it should be going
on purpose
intentionally you know too many people
to go Ready Aim aim aim aim aim aim Aim
Fire you got to pull the trigger and you
got to you know you're going to hit what
you aim at and if you aim at nothing you
will hit it every time Z Ziggler said
that and he's exactly right and so John
Maxwell says a budget is uh people
telling their money what to do instead
of wondering where it went that's and
that's again you feel like you got a
raise you have a sense of control even
if you can't pay every
you'd get a sense of Peace because you
know that you can pay the things you
have to pay like food yes and lights and
water and house payment and oh well I
got this one Master Card I can't get to
this month okay then we got to sell
something we got to get an extra job it
starts to you starts to solution almost
immediately yeah and you get you get
that sense of power over you making the
choices instead of it just happening to
you right and the other thing that
happens is when you got that much
Financial stress with eight credit cards
or nine credit cards and they're all
behind and two of them are in lawsuits
MH that much Financial stress in the
house 100% of the time it takes an
effect on your marriage oh 100% I can
vouch for that me too all those in favor
it was it was this moment in our
marriage that Sharon realized she had
married Gober not sir Galahad so uh
there we go she realized I screwed up I
picked poorly oh man that's what that's
what she had decided at this point but
yeah I mean that it it it takes away
your selfconfidence
it uh puts Terror in the relationship
it's there's nothing good about being
out of control no nothing good and you
know I could hear in that last caller in
his voice and I what I heard in his
voice was a a a sound I'd heard in Sam's
voice yeah I heard it in mind I little
is this like um this uncertainty fear a
little fear creeping into the
uncertainty and there's that guilt you
know it's like so I went and got a
lawyer and the lawyer said oh I'll take
your money oh man asking a you know I
was really surprised he didn't say file
bankruptcy cuz asking a bankruptcy
attorney if you're bankrupt like asking
a dog if it's hungry yeah I mean you
know it's like oh yes of course you're
bankrupt you came here didn't you you
know that's good to mention Dave because
people get scared when credit card
companies say I'm going to sue you and
we're F filing a lawsuit and your your
first thought is well I better lawyer
lawyer up too but you do owe them the
money like this is a movie yeah this is
not a movie you are not on trial mhm the
fact that you didn't pay a credit card
is on trial and Let Me Tell You Folks
here's what happens okay you ought to
actually have you you probably never
done this have you ever gotten a
speeding ticket I have gotten one
speeding ticket did you go to traffic
court I did go to and it meant nothing I
had to pay that you still they still
charge you anyway but traffic court is a
little bit like um a joke yeah I mean
you go in the judge goes okay uh you 17
people that came in here that are here
that this is your first offense uh go to
school or we'll just wave it or whatever
they do okay and it's like and you're
all geared up like you got your
arguments in your head it was foggy and
the officer SM alcohol on his breath and
you have all these things in your head
right that you're going to say and the
judg is like yawns and goes dismiss
dismiss dismiss dismissed and it's it's
it's anticlimactic well why did I have
to pay mine why I don't know I that
that's a personal problem but um let me
get all the dismissal list I don't know
I I have I have my theories but I'm not
going to bring it up it could be that
you were driving 200 mph
no no Dave not me not me but the uh Sam
Sam's going to tell me the truth later
but the um seriously though when you go
to small claims court or a small claim
even if it's not technically called
small claims court and you go in and the
attorney is suing you for $33,000 on a
credit card here's what happens folks
the attorney shows up with a
two-wheeler he's got so many
files and there's like a thousand
literally cases on that judge's docket
this morning and the judge is going to
go bump on all of them except the three
people that show
up and the judge is going to go you guys
go out in the hall with the attorney and
cut a deal interesting it's it's so lame
and
anticlimactic because here's the deal if
you owe someone money and you have
signed a contract like a credit card
agreement to pay them money and you
didn't pay them the money there's only
one possible result of the lawsuit you
lose the lawsuit cuz you didn't pay them
yeah you're in viol I mean showing up
and going I tried I tried your honor is
not an defense I lost my job your honor
is not a defense I got cancer it doesn't
matter you didn't pay the bill pay the
bill didn't pay the bill that's all that
matters if you got proof you paid it
that' be the only time and and they've
got they've done the accounting wrong or
something that' be the only time you
could possibly win the lawsuit but if
you haven't paid the bill you lose
that's right now then what happens
nothing yeah the only consolation is you
can settle for then you go back now you
settle the lawsuit instead of settling
the credit card debt whoopy it's it's
such
a the we get this emotion buil up cuz
the collector's like we are going they
play music in the background bu bu
everything's in big going going to sue
you and you're going no please anything
don't sue me please anything I'll do
anything yeah and that that's exactly
what they want that is true it's all
emotional we think Perry Mason is about
to come in there and Par Mason I you
were watching reruns as a a kid wow I
would have gone I would have at least
gone Matlock that's two decades later
there you go Matlock I'll take matlock's
but both of them are dead I'll just
saying but oh my gosh oh it's a mo there
not a modern day lawyer thing is there
oh yeah yeah there's got to be like like
uh Law And Justice La law La law those
guys were characters themselves anyway
yeah so anyway the uh yeah there's
nothing like that going on this is not a
courtroom drama right it's a factory
that produces lawsuits very efficiently
Bo you're done just like that just like
stamped out another widget and you be it
so just chill about the lawsuit it's not
I don't want you to get sued you don't
want to get sued but if I can't settle
it and they're going to take me to no
don't worry about it just keep working
it if you pay them money they're going
to go away that's right until you pay
them money they're not going to go away
you owe them money that's how this works
but they don't like to settle you do
have like before you even get to all
this you have to call so many times to
get them to take your to get them to
take your deal yeah let me let me let me
let me rephrase that they love to settle
they don't like to settle easily there
you go that's even better they want to
milk as much out of the deal as they can
milk cuz they finally found a cow cuz
usually they can't even find the cow
it's just loose it's running around in
the country somewhere they can't find
the cow but if you show up and they go
oh I got a cow I'm going to milk this as
far as I can that's what they're doing
so uh yeah they love to settle cuz they
bought these debts usually Pennies on
the dollar if they're a debt buyer on
Old bad debts and uh they probably got F
they probably got a nickel on the dollar
in it so on 3,000 bucks they probably
got $150 in it it's what they paid for
the debt so will they settle that do
they want do they like to settle oh yeah
it's their whole thing cuz you think
about all the cows that got loose we
just got one we're going to milk it
maybe we can get a grand out of this
three grand and it'll pay for 10 of the
other cards that I can't even find the
cow it just disappeared cuz I got one
that showed up here so they'll work with
you folks you just got to get up in
there facing but you've got to get
organized you've got to get on a budget
you have to buy your food for your
children first your lights and water and
your shelter second and third before you
do anything else don't talk to me about
I settled a credit card and now we don't
have any food right no no no no no no no
master card not that important they not
the master they just the card that's it
no you work it you work it you work it
it's a system it's a process for the
them it's all business for you it's all
emotions get the emotion out of it when
you lay it out on a plan use the every
dollar app and get your crap together
and get this mess cleaned
[Music]
up hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
[Applause]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality my
co-host today open phones atle
88255 225 Ryan's in Green Bay Wisconsin
hey Ryan how are
you great and yourself better than I
deserve what's up
hi so uh me and my wife are on baby step
six right now and my dad's Uncle
recently approached us about buying a 40
acres up on our family land up north and
we're debating if it's worth going back
to baby step two or
not so you're saying that you would go
back into debt to get this land as
opposed to pay off your current home
short correct for a short period of Time
how much is the
land um $40,000 $1,000 an acre and where
is it how far away from
you and now we're north of here and you
want it for
what uh we use it for hunting I mean our
whole family has it's been in our family
our whole life so we got 300 acres up
there that we family share and this 40
acres is part of the
300 correct so what happens if you don't
buy
it um that's a good question I don't
know I mean does your uncle want to keep
it he wants to sell it somebody else in
the family or he's going to hold it
right well thing is is he's tight for
money so he wants he wants the money
it's worth about 250 to 275,000 is there
anyone else in the family wait a minute
the 40 acres that is hunting land is
worth
$250,000
correct this is not hunting land
anymore not at that price I mean deer
meat is not that big a deal
dude this is expensive deer meat I mean
you're paying like $80,000 an ounce
here well you know I mean seriously this
is not hunting property's cheap property
250,000
bucks what I mean this must have some
proximity to uh this is this is not out
in the country somewhere this is close
to
town well that that's what it's worth
like I said we would be buying it for
only 40
so yeah I'm I something's wrong with
this equation okay either this is not
hunting property that it is close to a
metro area or it's not worth that cuz
hunting land you don't pay $250,000 for
40 acres to hunt
on up here it
is well you don't have the money to buy
it right now that's what I let's go back
to that I would not go back to baby step
2 and I would not pull out another okay
pull out debt on this let's just pretend
I could buy something that's worth 250
for 40 and I don't have the 40 I can't
buy
it let's just pretend that all of that
is accurate okay I can't buy something I
don't have the money for now uh he wants
the money now cuz he's hard up for money
so I guess another relative is going to
do this deal uh if you have something
you can cash in or sell uh sell your
truck yeah you could do that get you a
hoopie get rid of your $30,000 truck and
then you know go go have big garage sale
work six jobs and close on it and uh by
end of the end of the year and pay him
cash okay if you want to do that that's
fine but I'm calling BS okay there's
something wrong with this I buy I bought
real estate my whole life I own several
hundred million dollar worth of real
estate I've got a 250 Acre Farm in that
mix okay and dude no
way you don't buy stuff to hunt deer on
for 250 Grand not even in Michigan not
even in Wisconsin wherever you are oh my
God no no no unless you pay cash I
wouldn't do it you do whatever you want
to do Ryan but that's what we tell
people it's a toy and extra properties
and second homes are toys yeah pay cash
and you pay cash for
them and um and even if it's a good deal
it's not a good deal if you can't afford
it yeah you know the shirt is half off
but I got no money it's not a bargain
shirt's not half off that's right didn't
get the shirt it's same deal I mean it's
not a bargain when you can't afford it
so um and I I just hear rationalization
and yeah nope don't believe it Joe's in
Youngstown Ohio Hey Joe what's
up hey Dave thanks for taking my call
sure um I am about $130,000 in debt um
on what and a lot of it is uh well the
majority is my truck and my wife's car
which is how much each um the truck is
40,000 and the wife's car is at 15,000
okay so you're the problem
okay what else well that is a lot
of sorry I went straight to it is only
30,000 a year right now you said 30,000
what yes you're in income is
30k yes who and whose income is that is
that just one or one or the other or is
that both of you
combined that's just me uh my wife is a
stay home mom right now how many kids
three okay what what's the rest of
130,000 okay so I own a home in uh PA
that I don't that I don't live at I have
it on land contract which was a mistake
you sold it on land contract cont or you
bought it on land contract
I sold it online
contract okay so that one is still
15,000 on the mortgage and 20 28,000 on
the line of credit that was with that is
the payment coming in enough to cover
those
two yes okay so that that's the purpose
of a land contract all right so right
now that's a break even it's not your
issue okay right that's 45 of the
130 right 90 so there's another 40
what's the other
40 uh a lot of it is I had a I was
self-employed for quite a few years and
so I made some mistakes with uh some job
estimations that I did and so I own owe
quite a few metal companies a lot of
money for metal like there's and how
long has it been since you paid
them uh it's been months okay is it
companies or company so you got 40K in
Vendor
debt yes there is actually
31,800 precisely in in okay building
materials there's another 8,000 floating
somewhere what is it um it is personal
loans from uh small lenders and stuff
for just what happened to your income
because you used to make
more I did um I quit my business because
I was going through a struggle for a
short period of time and I I decided
that I'm just going to quit go for a job
and it didn't work out so I started my I
started a new company later um two years
ago actually and I do right now I am
self-employed I do a commercial roofing
and it's just my I have been struggling
more than I have ever struggled with a
business so um here's my thing and until
your business is making you enough money
to float your lifestyle it's really just
a hobby or a side hustle and I commend
you for starting that business but it's
not making enough money to to manage
your household bills obviously so you've
got to treat it like a side Hustle
that's got to be something you're doing
on the side and building while you have
a full-time job what how much how long
you been doing that the the current
business two years yeah yeah okay Jade's
right I mean that thing should have been
pushed to the side as a side hustle
about 18 months ago or I do also I also
work with another uh commercial roofing
company that I work for like three two
to three sometimes four days a week I
mean that's great but wouldn't are you
going to argue that 30,000 is cutting
fitting the bill right now cuz it's not
no absolutely not is the 30 from your
business or the 30 is total of the two
that's that's total of the two yeah
you're not making enough uhhuh you used
to make close to six figures didn't
you I I have never made six figures I
mean I think the the most I ever made
was what 50,000 but okay there's two
there's two glaring things in your math
that are going on and part of what we do
here is we have the advantage of not
being in the forest so we can clearly
see the trees M okay the glaring things
are you have two cars that you could
never afford at any time in your life
they should never have been purchased
both of them belong in the crazy column
agre nuts sell them both get two 1,000
two $2,000 cars and then the second
glaring area is your income you've got
to do some things to get your income up
short term and longterm and I'd even be
looking at the wife staying at home I
want to know how young those kids are
cuz it might be that she can go out and
get some work as well cuz you worked
your tail end off yes when you guys were
getting out like crazy yeah so yeah
income is one side of the equation and
two cars in the cray cray column is the
other side of the equation if you get
those two things fixed your life's going
to shift very quickly and they'll get to
the good side that's right this is the
ramsy
show
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to ramsy
solutions.com today to sign up for our
newsletter again that's ramsy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
Newsletter
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade washaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today the
phone number if you want to talk Isle
88255 225 Nikki is starting this hour in
Miami hi Nikki welcome to the Ramsey
show thank you hello hi how can we
help so I was calling to see if I in
your opinion can afford or should I buy
a 1 point5 million house cool I know it
sounds like a lot it's not a lot in my
area it's actually I would even say a
fixer upper for 1.5 but it's in a great
desired neighborhood for schools Okay
cool so I wanted your opinion if that's
a move we should make at this point in
our lives
absolutely if you can AF if exact if you
can afford it exactly and that's my
question can I afford such a big
purchase so what's your household in
complicated yes so that's a complicated
part so my husband and I we make
$29,000 MH however we do um have rental
properties um as soon as we turned 25
instead of having a big old wedding we
took our money and we bought our first
investment property we paid it off moved
on to the next one paid that one off and
we've been building slowly but so two
rental properties free and
clear free and clear yeah we have four
in total um we have one left to pay off
out of the four can you tell me the
first three can you tell me what they're
worth of course so the first one um we
bought it for
200,000 and now it is worth 800,000 wow
good what about the second one and my
rental my cash my net cash every month
is close to $2,000 okay after all
expenses um my second property is paid
off as well bought it for
250,000 now it's worth 800,000 sweet way
to go what about and then the third one
yes then the third one also paid off and
right now it's currently worth
$350,000 and what do you owe on the one
that's not paid
off um
$330,000 and that one is worth around
700,000 okay and uh is there any other
debt that you
have just our cars um we owe between
both of us
$46,000 in cars they're fairly new we
ended up buying them just a few months
ago anything
else no no student credit card nothing
like you have any cash um we do we have
about
150 and then for aside from our income
of 290 we also have our rental income
which Nets to about
95,000 a year so that's separate from
the
290 that's correct that's an addition
too the um okay and do you have any
other
Investments no just oh retirement for
onek how
much um close to 160 how old are you
guys um I am 37 and my husband is 40
well you've done extremely well
congratulations thank you parents um the
uh uh and you're fairly new to this
ramsy stuff I think aren't you I I did I
started watching the show and your
videos just a couple of weeks ago and as
much money as you've got and as well as
you've done why do you care what we
think
um I will both of my husband and I were
accountants so we've gone so far we've
been we sacrific so much in our 20s and
30s to get where we are I don't want to
make the wrong move over a dream that is
expensive I don't the reason you built
wealth
accountant is to live the dream not
count the
coin correct okay so you're going to
give up some of your rental income in
order to live the dream
M if I'm you anyway I've got a bunch of
rental property I love rental property I
love real estate all of mine's paid for
I never borrow money for anything my
house is paid for everything's paid for
everything's paid for everything's paid
for so I'm going to have you in a in a
paid for
Dreamhouse by selling off some of your
rentals if I'm doing your
deal now that makes you a question
whether you really want to do this or
not because now the accountant is
fighting with the little girl who wanted
a dreamhouse now who's going to win it
is well look it is we have discussed
that option but we don't want to let go
it's cash flow yeah it is but would you
rather strangers live in the paid for
house or you that's the way I look at it
I'd much be willing to clear I'd
probably clear rental number four since
there's debt on it anyway I'd sell that
one and get 300,000 cash and drop one of
the 800s I drop one of the 800s and and
pay cash for this puppy and you're the
one living in the paid for
house not one of your rers no makes
sense yeah right it's funny I'm my
houses out and I live inment what what
do you live now what do you live in
now that's I I rented all of my houses
and I'm the one living in an apartment
wow okay okay and you're 37 and you're a
37y old multi you're a 37y old
multi-millionaire with an income
approaching a half million doll a
year and I'm still questioning what I
should do yeah well I listen let me me
help you with this okay there's three
things you can do with money and you
need to do all three all the time be
generous with it invest it and enjoy it
you're only good at
one investing and you are a world class
investor but you suck at enjoying it
that is
true yes my husband says the same thing
we had this conversation last night
that's I said Taylor S tickets are too
expensive oh God this has nothing to do
with Taylor Swift but they better go see
it y'all better go see that show how did
Taylor Swift get in this conversation
because she put Kelsey on the map Dave
oh Jesus Murphy help me Lord help me La
it's too expensive I can't pay for those
fig what happen and he asked me what
happens if your daughter will ask for it
he made me think at that point I said I
got to think about it I got to justify
the yeah yeah so here's yeah what would
I listen listen I believe I teach people
to get out of debt I teach people to
save people that spend all the time
people that spend all of their money on
fun and have no life consequently except
of stress and problems so that most of
the people we talk to Jade and I are on
the other end we're telling them grow up
and quit being a child and have and quit
having all some fun enoy instead have
some generosity and some investing in
your life so I want you to insert some
generosity in your life you didn't talk
about that I'm not saying you don't have
that but I want to make sure it's there
and I want you to enjoy some of this
money here's the deal with the money
that you make if you sacrifice one and a
half rentals the one that's paid for and
the one that's not um and you get a nice
home and you take a normal amount and
start investing it from this point
forward you're going to be worth 25 to30
million at retirement wow that's where
you're headed mathematically and you're
an accountant you can do compound
interest and you know what it looks like
you have this fabulous income yeah and
better than that you have this thing
called self-control yeah and discipline
I mean you're weird it's awesome yeah
but you need to go get your good house
girl you earned it you earned it sure
did very good this is that's so fun way
to go way to go Nikki this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of Prayer pray and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation in
prayer is hallow hallow is the number
one Prayer app in the world and they're
giving you three months free to get
started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember Pao is giving you 90 days
free imagine the peaceful habits you can
establish in 90 days go to hall.com
Ramsey today and follow the simple
prompts to start your free 90-day trial
that's hall.com
Ramsey
[Music]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today today's question of the
day is brought to you by neighborly your
hub for Home Services when something in
your home breaks remember the neighborly
Done Right promise which is it's not
done right until it's done right that's
cool I like that download the neighborly
app today schedule your appointment and
uh you know you'll get great service
when you're working with neighborly
network of home service providers great
great company yeah today's question
comes from Rachel in Missouri she says
I've been listening to you for over 20
years and I'm so grateful for your
financial principles my family is close
to paying off for a mortgage and then we
are completely debt free will you please
give perspective on our world events
talking about the Israel at War Etc
what's the best advice to prepare
financially for our own home and how to
invest with so much turmoil this is an
interesting question Dave I'll give my
uh two cents on this I'd love to hear
your side of this um Rachel things like
this whenever there's Calamity whenever
there's uncertainty in the world I think
about Co and all those things uh I
really go quickly to controlling what I
can control and in this case like you
said you're close to paying off your
mortgage you're close to being
completely debt free do those things
that you know to do and continue walking
down that path and um and then for me I
just also have to accept it's like in
one hand I control the things that I can
control and then on the other hand I
have to accept the things that I can't
control and one thing that I have found
that helps me accept the things I can't
control is I tend to want to lean into
generosity a little bit and then there's
kind of just like okay I can't go
overseas and I may not be the one that
can save people but I can be generous in
my community there's things that I can
still do so that's the way that I would
approach that um and that are those are
the two things that have given me peace
uh in times like these what about you
Dave now that makes a lot of sense um
control the controllables I mean when we
were in the fouchy pandemic you know we
didn't know what was going to happen um
you know it was we' never been in a fouy
pandemic before you didn't know what to
do right and so um you know you just
kind of got to get in there and wind
your way through that one actually
showed up in Missouri I don't think
Kamas is going to show up in Missouri I
could be wrong but I'm pretty sure that
one um might be wrong I mean sure as I
say that it'll be tomorrow but I I don't
think so I think you're I think you're
probably okay but then the question is
what does world what do Global events do
to your Investments well if you're inv
in the stock market for instance in your
401k sometimes Global events temporarily
affect that uh a a scare in the Ukraine
a scare um in in Israel a war in Israel
a war in the Ukraine uh can affect uh
stock market usually fairly
temporarily um certainly an event in the
Homeland an event in the United States
proper would affect the stock market but
even 911 when the towers were uh
attacked by those cowards um and they
you know they they fell and they fell if
you don't know literally within blocks
of Wall Street the actual New York Stock
Exchange is right there okay you
couldn't get to it for a day or two
because of the rubble and so but also we
traditionally shut down the stock market
exchange the New York Stock Exchange and
for that matter the uh the NASDAQ which
is in Chicago will shut down Trading
during during horrible events like an
attack on American soil uh we shut it
down well it so it shut down the 911 was
on a Tuesday stock market didn't reopen
until Monday and as soon as it reopened
you know what it did it
Dove 500 points in a matter of
moments you know what it did and then it
went down like for a week it just kept
going down and everybody's like oh the
they they they've crash crashed the
towers and they crashed the American
economy no not even close I kept telling
people look buy buy buy it's time to buy
it's going down buy it's on sale buy I
don't want to take advantage of a
Calamity that's not the point but the
Market's going down this is not the time
to sell it's the time to buy because 54
days later it returned to where it was
which nobody talked about and never made
a single news headline but the news
headline big bold across the front page
of the the you know the the local uh
liberal pamphlet we have that's called a
newspaper and um big bold big bold
letter stock market crashes following
terrorist attack you know how much
coverage they gave it when 54 days later
it completely returned zero not one
mention not one anywhere even CNBC which
is supposed to report on business didn't
report it even Fox Business didn't
report it because Fox Business was not
in existence then so there and you know
but there you go that's what that's how
this world event things work
what you do is you keep buying so Dave
all the time you just keep buying the
rest of your life you keep buying until
it's time for you to sell you do not buy
or sell based on world events because
they always have a temporary impact so
we always say here that when you're
investing you're spreading it over four
types right growth growth and income
aggressive growth International and I
feel like I've heard you say
International is kind of like the Wild
Child right no it's the weak spot that's
the weak spot and that is because those
economies have not done as well right
and we know that overall in the United
States foreign stocks as a category have
not kept up with us stocks as a category
but's re for the for the last 40 years
there's a reason that it's still a
quarter of the strategy exactly because
there are times that things like a BMW
or a Mercedes were they still owned by
Germans they're not now but you know
were they you know think of a foreign
company then there's a bunch of them
that you ingest and do business with
every day and don't think anything about
it um but they're stock then is a
considered a foreign stock and so
there's times that they're going to
prosper sometimes on the back of the US
economy that's true but there's still
that that profit is from a foreign goes
to a foreign company then so uh it's not
a patriotic issue it's a math thing and
so um you just keep investing you just
keep investing Rachel and I got to tell
you if you're worried about a paid for
house in
Missouri because of the war in Israel
you need to turn the television off yeah
that's you're watching it too much
because that you your reality is getting
distorted um as to what's what the real
effect is going to be on your life I
absolutely no one is happy about Israel
being attacked well some people are
happy but I mean n none of the people
around me are people like me happy about
it we're all in horri horrified with
what's going on it's absolute evil but
um but from a financial or economic
perspective a year from now there'll be
a distant memory from a political
perspective 10 years from now it'll be a
history note in a book that's all it'll
be just a note that's true like the 1967
1972 same same date sit Israel right
same thing just a note in the history
book yeah and so but while you're living
in it it's a real thing and so but you
can't get caught up in things that are
happening somewhere else control the
controllables yeah it's tough I think um
the way the world is there's social
media there's 24hour a day Network news
right
and it's constantly feeding us the worst
possible things happening in society and
if we don't put boundaries around that
we will destroy our brains like we will
we will be in fear 247 it's a 24/7 news
cycle 24/7 fear cycle it's fear porn and
you know not to say that the Israel
thing is not real uh is obviously real
it's obviously horrid it's a tragedy
it's a disaster yeah it's all of those
things but um uh but it but is it going
to affect Rachel in Missouri no no no
other than pray for I was gonna say Pray
for Peace in Jerusalem yep other than
the way that we can sh compassion that's
all you can do hey thank you thank you
for your question Rachel open phones at
225 um by the way there's lots of
information on the stock market history
that is very intriguing when you dig
into it one piece of information I saw
in one of the brochures one time is if
you had invested at the worst possible
day in the stock market in The Last 5
Years and you did that every five years
MH you would have so much money the
worst possible day yeah because you were
buying at the bottom yeah cheap you know
and you say okay this is the horrible
thing that happened that right after 911
if you had invested right if you had
invested after you know Black Monday in
1987 if you'd which the market just do
like 20% in one day was crazy it's a
weird day if You' in ined on the worst
possible days if you invested at the
highest possible days how much money
you'd have and it's still a lot of money
something so the point of the chart or
the illustration is keep investing keep
investing keep investing the only people
that get hurt on a roller coaster or
those that jump off in the middle of the
ride this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsey we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level net week gave
us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it scaled with us net
week worked for ramsy and it will will
make a difference for your business too
join the more than 34,000 customers who
trust netsuite to help make them smarter
and make better decisions and level up
their operations to learn more get a
free product tour at nets.com
Ramsey that's nets.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Derek is in Salt Lake City
hi Dereck welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave hi Jade hey what's
up hey um I'm getting married in less
than two months
congratulations has oh thank you very
much um she has about
$23,000 uh of Consumer Debt I do not
have any debt outside of my mortgage so
my question to you is should I stop baby
steps 45 and six and save up uh to be
able to pay off her debts after the
wedding or should I continue 4 five and
six till after the wedding so you don't
have 23,000 cash
now um I do yes okay why would you need
why would you need to save up then um
I'm I'm currently finishing my basement
and so um I'm doing that debt free and
so I'm only going to have about 15,000
left and is she contributing any to this
23,000 uh she's working um to pay it off
right now but when we get married it'll
still the line share will still be there
okay so you've got 15,000 that you can
put towards it
yeah I I would yes yes to answer your
question I would stop my
401k and go ahead and get get ready for
the Post honeymoon debt Freedom M and
then make sure you have a fully funded
emergency fund and um never dip into
your emergency fund for anything and
that includes fixing a basement which is
by definition not an
emergency and um then we will after we
have an emergency fund in place we'll
restart and put 15% of our new household
income into retirement plans of some
kind
okay that makes sense yeah that's uh
that's just adjusting both of your lives
to fit the the post marriage baby steps
agreed definitely yeah you you were on
track you knew what we were going to say
already but you just want to make sure
that the Nuance was there MH yeah I I
was I had a couple more questions for
him I wanted to know if he was spending
his emergency fund to do his basement
well he had 23,000 he's going to be down
to 15 yeah so I don't I don't know how
far you know that's what I said you got
to make sure the emergency fund's in
place and the basement's not yeah yeah
but um yeah that's um yeah we went from
this real Noble I'm going to pay off my
fiance's debt after we're married to I'm
finishing my basement yeah your face was
priceless what finish in my basement
yeah all right there's that okay how are
these in the same
sentence yeah that's good that's okay
she wants maybe she wants the basement
finished yeah it's okay nothing's wrong
with what he's doing it's just it just
caught me off guard cuz it like a hard
left turn it was Morgan is in Sacramento
hey Morgan what's up hi how's it going
better than I deserve how can I help yay
um I am calling because I have been a
homeschooling stay-at-home mom for the
past 18 years and my kids have just
gotten old enough now to where I am
working part-time and we're trying to
figure out what to do with um my added
income
some of it is going to H is um sorry
going to help make ends meet with
inflation and all that fun going on but
we still have an abundance beyond that
and so we're trying to figure out how to
if we in comparison with elevating our
lifestyle with paying off the mortgage
so you're on baby step
six I think so awesome so that would
mean for anybody listening you have no
other debt other than the mortgage
you've got 3 to 6 months set aside for
expenses in an emergency fund yep and
you're investing 15% of your
income yes before taxes and then are you
putting aside anything into 529s or
anything like that for the kids college
uh no that stuff is all taken care of oh
okay
oh how's it taken care of oh wow I'm
sorry I said wow I said yeah um my
oldest was given a 529 already and has
done scholarships and is working working
her way through this is her first year
and um we also have relatives that are
helping along the way and are able to
help but um we just really feel strongly
too about our kids work ethic and being
able to put themselves through we live
in an area too that has a state school
and a community college and here in
California Community College is paid for
by taxpayers so there's just a lot of
support so they're able to go without
debt so that's good yes yeah but you're
you're contributing nothing
uh yeah correct okay so taking care of
means that you think they have a
plan yes yeah that's true okay I just
wanted to know what you meant okay yeah
and um all right so I I get it that's
been the plan they're homeschool and
that's been the plan all along and they
know that they're not surprised by it
and you're actually coaching them and
showing them how to do this debt-free I
hope and um and uh without Mom and Dad's
support and with the support of some
relative money money coming from some
relatives okay cool y um well I mean
there's two things to do with the
overage then it'd be baby step six as
you said put it on your house or enjoy
it um how much overage have you
got um probably about a thousand a month
okay so what do you want to do too um
you know little things like my daughter
this year asked if she could have new
soccer shoes instead of used soccer
shoes things like that like I really
would like to do and what but we
actually did do um for my birthday we
bought a table at a banquet for a
charity event for people and that was so
much fun to be able to do that um my
husband likes to buy dinner if we ever
go out with
friends um so you know nothing huge I
guess I mean but then that's what we're
thinking like oh maybe we could save up
and go to next year's money and marriage
events you know things like that that
are super exciting what I would say what
I would say this is what Sam and I do um
and we we we came up with this because
we have variable like variable income
and every month the question is what do
we do with this extra income and finally
we got to the point where like it's just
a percentage and we know this percentage
is going towards a mortgage whatever is
this percentage goes towards something
fun we want to do and this percentage
goes towards giving and that kind of
takes all of the guess work out of it it
kind of takes the um the tendency to
maybe leave something that's important
out and so that you can do something
else and that way it's like okay we're
covering every base every time there's
extra money and that's one strategy you
could utilize with this because I do
want you to be intentional about paying
off your mortgage because it is part of
the process and it's very important for
you to do that in order to build wealth
but like Dave said you also it's extra
right and you don't have to be so so
intense about it I just want you to be
intentional so you do have the
opportunity to give some or save some as
well yeah I I would I agree with that I
think that's a great formula and so it
might sound like we're going to put 50%
of all over overage towards the mortgage
uh we're going to splurge with 40% of
the overage and we're going to give an
additional 10 yeah um for generosity out
of out of it or whatever you could you
can switch those numbers around or you
can have different numbers but the
obviously out of $1,000 then I'd put 500
towards a mortgage or 500 you know
whatever that percentage tells you and
that's exactly how Sharon and I do it as
well we increase our Lifestyle by a very
small percentage on all overage we
increase our generosity and are
investing by a large percentage on all
overage um but we're blessed in that our
income is so freaking ridiculous that a
small percentage is a great for life so
um I mean our lifestyle increasing a
small percentage is not a small dollar
so it's good we just don't need to spend
that much it's just nuts and we still
have a crazy good life you do you do I
think people do fear like lifestyle
creep
though you should you should fear it
yeah because I mean it cuz if you don't
learn to control how much you spend on
your consumption MH you will consume all
of it the rest of your life no matter
what you make and people would make $15
million buy $15 million worth of stupid
stuff then you know that's called M
Money Mo Problems that's it and that's
that's a you know mo immaturity yeah so
um it just keeps growing right but yeah
I think you just got to uh you're but
the formula gives you permission to
enjoy the portion that you set for
enjoyment and permission to do the
generosity without looking over your
shoulder was I irresponsible that's
right and permission to do the investing
without feeling like I'm Scrooge McDuck
counting my coins right right that's
right and so I love that where we
allocate a percentage I use it we teach
it to high income people all the time
but it works for anybody in four five
and six on any amount of overage it
could be a th000 it could be 10,000
overage whatever it is good suggestion
Jade well done this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them them from blinds
drapes and shutters to motorized Shades
they make it easy and affordable to
upgrade your entire home and their team
is ready to help with everything from
design consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40% off everything sitewide
go to blinds.com for more
[Music]
information
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
88255 225 James is in Santa Cruz
California hi James how are you oh very
good thank you um I am a new listener my
radio station just picked you guys up
and couple
questions um on credit scores we had
bankruptcy years and years ago and we've
just been working real hard on bringing
our credit up and now we're in the
800s and I heard you the other day
saying that isn't that important so I'm
just trying
to find out about credit ratings yeah so
James well number one thanks for
listening and thanks for even being open
to what we're talking about here um the
thing with the credit score is it's all
about your interaction with debt and
since you have started listening we are
of the camp that debt is there's no such
thing as good debt right we want you to
pay off your debt and when you do pay
off your debt your credit score goes to
zero After Time usually it's about a
year that passes and it will go down to
zero if you have no debt on the record
and for a lot of people yourself
included I think that is completely new
information it's like wow I didn't know
that that was possible and it makes
people a little bit nervous because our
whole lives the culture is telling us
you need to have credit score you need
to have good credit score and you need a
credit score to get all the things that
you want in life but when you really do
look at that score it's about how much
debt you have how long you've interacted
with that debt what types of debt do you
have right the history of your debt what
percentage of your debt that you're
using that's all they care about and
it's only good for one thing and that's
to help you get more
debt right it it's not it's not an it's
not an indication that you have a high
net worth a high income it's not an
indication you're winning with money
it's an indication you're winning with
debt MH and so it's a false measure of
winning is our is our point and do we
want to purposefully destroy it if
you've got an 800 no but the only way
you've got an 800 is since you filed
bankruptcy years ago is you know after
the bankruptcy you've had a lot of
positive inter action with debt meaning
you borrowed paid it back borrowed paid
it back on time or early and uh you
didn't get into crazy amounts of debt I
hope um usually you don't get an 800 if
you're way overleveraged right um and
usually you don't get an 800 if you've
got a bunch of wrong kinds of debt I
mean if you had by wrong kinds I mean
the super dumb stuff yeah right but it's
not all credit card debt or it's not all
whatever but I mean you've been living a
fairly normal consumer life and have
paid everything earlier on time am I
right yeah and you know we have four
vehicles everything's paid off we have
you know credit cards but I mean we pay
them off every month right right and the
only but you didn't always or you
wouldn't have an 800 no correct the
credit the cars weren't always paid off
and the credit cards weren't always paid
off every month or you would not have an
800 right the only thing we have is our
mortgage and I just looked it up
yesterday and it's worth like 1.2 and we
owe 513 so it's like a
$687,000 an equity yeah way to go way to
go we have two kids our girl is the last
two years at CH yeah so we're paying
their Tu what's your hous what's your
household income
um the wife is around
125 and I'm self-employed I'm and I
actually retired this last
December which doesn't feel like it
because I'm still working yeah what do
you make what do you make I I'm on paper
um about 20 to 30 okay so let me let me
here's the premise you're a brand new
listener the thing that we've discovered
and I've lived and we have taught now
for 30 years on this show is the
shortest fastest way to an extremely
stable
wealthy enjoyment of money is to become
and stay debt-free because that frees up
your income it de it takes away the risk
of problems and you're living in a
fairly risk-free environment right now
you have nothing left but a very small
Mortgage in relative to the
uh relative to the value and your wife
has a good income you guys have done
you've been very careful calm wise
you've not done anything super stupid
here you've done a good job a very good
job and so it doesn't in your mind right
now this idea of living without debt
completely uh it's not that radical
because you're almost there
basically right and then then the point
being the point being do you want to go
back into debt if you want to go back
into debt I would argue with you if you
if you want to go back into debt you
should protect that credit score because
it's the easiest way to go into debt but
if you're not going to borrow anymore
and you're just going to build wealth
and the next time you get ready to buy a
car or put a kid in school you're going
to figure out a way to write a check to
do that and you're not going to borrow
money then your need for an 800 credit
score is very low yeah now you don't
have to worry about it it's not do
anything wrong it's just sitting there
and there's no sensing like I said we
don't need to shoot it or something it's
not want to destroy it uh but I'm not
going to sit and fret like most of
Americans do about oh God it dropped 10
points who gives a crap I mean it
doesn't matter you're not using it it
has only one use and that's to borrow
more money and if you decide like I
decided 30 years ago and you've been
moving this way before you even met us
James you've been moving towards being
debt-free and hopefully staying that way
if you decide I'm going to stay that way
then you have no use for a credit score
right yeah and the the further you walk
down the path the easier it gets right
when you when you first start out you've
got a bunch of debt and there's you know
more risk in your life you're thinking
well I a lot of people erroneously think
I need a credit card what if something
happens it's my safety net and then they
start to realize and get their
confidence of wait a minute I can use my
own money I don't need this credit score
and the further you get down that line
to where maybe the only thing you have
left is your mortgage then it's like
yeah what do I need a credit score for
I've got everything and I was able and
now I have all this extra cash because I
don't have payments so if I do need
something I can EAS easily stack up the
cash to pay cash I don't need debt
that's it once you know that then you
don't need a score yeah that's right
that's James thanks for being a brand
new listener Caleb is in Charleston West
Virginia hi Caleb how are you I'm great
Dave how are you doing better than I
deserve what's
up so I uh I do reside in Charleston
West Virginia I own a roofing company
we're coming up on uh just over two and
a half years in
business and uh Fair fairly healthy we
will be uh projecting about 2.2 million
in good job well done thank you um and
we've accumulated a decent amount of
money I've got actually just checked it
this morning around 33,000 and change in
the bank but it is just sitting um in
the bank so I can give you a little bit
more details of kind of our family we've
got two two young girls and it's when
you work pretty hard for you know that
type of money you you seem to you know
keep it closer to your chest and I I
don't know if I'm I'm doing you know
this service to myself as well as the
family if we don't pick up a little bit
you know and be more aggressive in well
you need an emergency funded home you
need retained to earnings at the office
you need some money some cash at the
office for operations for growth for uh
for buying things uh so you don't use a
line of credit at the office that kind
of stuff so I keep a retained earnings
fund here at Ramsey all right and then
at home I've got an emergency fund so
some of that 300 will be allocated to
those two things the rest of it should
be either used to pay off debt or to
invest or both depending on where you
are in the baby
steps okay are you familiar with the
baby steps I am I am familiar okay where
are you are you out of
debt no and you're gonna you're probably
with with the type of money and again
it's it's one of those things where it's
sometimes hard to give up some of the
the money that I've I've worked uh and
you already gave it up when you bought
the item with debt you just hadn't
admitted it yet yeah that's what I want
to know do you have I mean you did 2.2
million in Revenue but does the business
did you guys take out debt on the
business no the business has zero debt
at all what's the debt that you're
ashamed of that you don't want to talk
about 130,000 in my mortgage oh is that
all oh is that all I have 130 I have
130,000 mortgage that's it that's not
that's that's no biggie pay it off man
oh God pay that off today good Lord I
thought he was gonna drop a bomb on us D
I thought you were gonna tell me you had
$80,000 truck uhuh I really did yeah oh
my God no pay off that mortgage man
today great exciting stuff yeah and then
you still
got 15,000 15 180,000 bucks yeah oh my
gosh this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show Dave here you can find all of our
shows with the Ramsey Network app on
your smartphone it's the only place to
listen to the entire back catalog of
episodes download the Ramsey Network app
in your favorite app store
[Music]
today
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade Wasa Ramsey
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us the phone number is
88255 225 Brian is in Minneapolis
Minnesota hi Brian welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's
up yeah so my wife and I we are both 25
years old um we got roughly
$35,000 in debt um and that is pretty
well just consumed in vehicles um I got
a truck and she got a SUV um we got our
first child on the way and we are just
looking for some advice as far as
getting out of debt and stopping living
paycheck to
paycheck so you've got 35,000 and two
separate cars can you just break that
down for me right
quick yep so uh the truck we have about
125 that we owe uhhuh and what whatever
the remaining balance is from that is
sure is what my wife always on the
vehicle okay got it and so what's your
income uh so our combined income it
varies a little bit because I am full
commission um sales however combined we
we gross roughly 120 a year okay 120 a
year good for you that is good um you
know when I look at 35,000 in cars I
don't think with your income I'm not
like oh my gosh you guys are out of
control but I am wondering where is your
income going and my first question to
you is if you're on a budget or
not so we are not um and we actually
just started the baby steps so we paid
off we got our emergency fund we paid
off our
debt um just last week and so we need to
get a budget together um because it's
kind of a deal where you know every
paycheck it's like where the heck's our
money going yeah so I think you got a
lot going on in your life you got this
debt you want to get it cleared up
you've got baby coming up you want to
get that cleared up um what I want to
tell you is I know you want to get out
of debt and that's good but during this
time what I really want you focused on
is just piling up as much money as you
possibly can until baby comes yes
because when the baby gets here
everything's going to be fine wife's
going to be fine that's the goal right
like that's the hope we and want and so
when the baby gets here everybody's
healthy then you can take that big chunk
of money and attack these cars in order
small toar so hit the truck first you
should have more than enough to pay off
her car the day baby comes home from the
hospital MH yep okay and put a and put I
mean not her car well e either car you
you you you know you might have the 22
,000 but you definitely have the 12,000
agreed right yeah so pile it up as big
as you can pile it start your debt
snowball hard and fast with that big
pile of cash is what Jade's saying when
the baby comes home in the meantime I
like just having a big pile of cash when
a baby's on the
way yes and that's kind of what I was
wondering is you know I don't want the
baby to show up and then we have no
money well I'm not I'm not worried about
you being able to feed the baby that's
you can do that on 120 I'm just in in
case there's a a a little medical hiccup
or something you want to concentrate on
baby and on Mommy not on debt that's
right so you know having no money with a
baby on the way is scary so let's just
pile it up get on that written detailed
budget use that every dollar app you and
your wife sit down lay out where every
dollar is going to go every month before
the month begins every dollar has an
assignment every dollar has a name every
dollar has a mission you both agree to
it you pinky swear and shake and you
freaking stick to it yeah cuz at the
very least you know you're going to hit
that deductible and you're going to have
to pay that out of pocket which
depending on your insurance could be
pretty high if you've got a high
deductible plan so you know you're at
least going to hit that with the baby
yeah you're going to have that and you
know and we want to pay a car or two off
yeah so it would be very cool and how
much money can you save in nine months I
mean $9,000 $110,000 I mean hey let me
ask you something about that so somebody
mentioned if you know you're having a
baby going into the hospital
upfront that there's an advantage to
going in and paying Upfront for the
delivery cost if you don't have
insurance if only if you don't have
insurance yeah if you have insurance
it's all s it doesn't matter it doesn't
change anything because the insurance
company's already cut the deal does they
have baby cost X deal uhhuh okay the
insurance company does but if you've got
I don't know in let's just say labor and
delivery is 12,000 bucks as an example I
don't know what it is I haven't PID in a
long long time but let's just say that's
probably about what it is give or take
right now and if if you did not have
insurance which would be highly unusual
in today's world that's why I was trying
to get around that if you did not have
insurance it is the it's an very
interesting thing with hospitals it's
the only time you go to the hospital
that you're
glad that's true so babies are PR good
PR for hospitals well people come there
and everybody that comes about the
baby's happy and the baby's Happy Well
Mama's not glad until after I me but I
mean is a celebratory event that's right
it's not having your appendix out okay
it's not it's not having your knee
replacement surgery done it's not your
mother died of gallbladder disease there
it's not that you know it's not people
go to hospitals to die it's not that
right it's the only time that it's a
happy story that's right and so
hospitals want people to have babies
there yeah because it's a good thing for
them from a PR perspective it puts Good
Vibes into the community right so with
all that in mind you can go in ahead of
time and negotiate and prepay uh and
they'll cut as much as half off that's
pretty in labor and delivery they
probably will do it on other procedures
but they're known for doing it
industrywide yeah on labor and delivery
so which tells us that we're paying too
much through insurance but our insurance
is paying it but we're paying the
insurance and yeah yeah there we go but
anyway the way mine was you the the
doctor's office set up your whatever
your deductible was and they were like
you pay half now you pay this much and
then by the time the baby was done you
had already done it yep and it and it
really wasn't optional it's a program
yeah but again if
you're this would have been a while you
know pre- Obamacare as an example there
were people more people walking around
without insurance that's right now they
just pay twice as much for it but um but
there were more people walking around
the insurance out insurance in those
days mhm so you could go in and
pre-negotiate and uh um uh I mean we had
great success with that back in the day
I don't know how that much that would
apply today because I don't know how
often somebody actually goes into a
hospital for labor and delivery without
insurance be fair that's true true
Austin is in Jackson Miss hi Austin
welcome to the ramsy show hey Austin
you're going to hang on till the next
break I just looked up and saw the time
sorry about that I'm not going to try to
answer your question in 15 or 20 seconds
yeah that doesn't work at all
so I I suspect if you had elective
surgeries that were not insurance
covered that you probably could also go
in ahead of time and say if I prepay
what kind of deal will you get me and
I'm shopping other locations to do this
elective surgery that's true yeah I like
that I like that so I mean even
something again something would not be
insurance covered that has not been
dictated but um yeah I suspect you could
do that there as well cuz you've got
choices then you don't a you don't have
to do it B you certainly don't have to
do it there that's right and so again
your walkway power from a negotiation
standpoint is intact this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
88255 225 Austin is in Jackson
Mississippi hey Austin how are
you Austin are you with me yep can you
hear me yes sir how can we help uh I
hope you both are doing well today so I
re recently probably within the last few
weeks uh stumbled upon your content and
I'm just trying to wrap my head around
uh I have a 6% uh salary match uh 401k
and I'm trying to wrap my head around
foregoing that and putting in uh
straight into debt and if was looking
for an explanation that's a great
question it means you're being very
thoughtful about all of this very well
done so what do you do for a
living so I am actually a uh purchasing
manager for a mine okay and so you um
have a degree in Business possibly yes
okay good I thought I thought so um so
because you're good at you're good at
seeing the the math thing right in front
of you and going well that seems dumb so
here's a couple of things that we
discovered and I I honestly doing this
for 30 years uh 25 years ago I was
backing into some of these ideas because
I come from the same academic background
but back when the dinosaurs roam the
Earth that you came from okay mhm and so
my my first tendency is to nerd out and
fix everything with math mhm but I
figured out in personal finance that the
data of best practices among
millionaires doesn't necessarily follow
math all the time right in other words
personal finance is more personal than
it is finance it's more Behavior than it
is math and so what we've discovered
over the year Decades of doing this is
that in other words here's an example
the power of exclusively focusing all of
your money energy your arithmatic energy
on one goal for a short period of time
supersedes the employer match yeah the
power
Focus although that's a little bit
nebulous and hard to put a math figure
too we've proven that over a decade
getting clear of Consumer Debt very very
quick
increases the probability that you
actually do it number one mhm but number
two uh it gets you out of debt and
freeze up then your most powerful wealth
building tool which is your income when
you bifurcate your focuses meaning you
spread them out when you spread out
light it merely lights a room when you
focus it you can do surgery or
manufacture things with it called a
laser and what we're doing here is for a
short period of time not an extended
period of time they won't the the Theory
doesn't stand up and the hypothesis
doesn't stand up over a long period of
time but for three years or less if you
forgo a match and forgo forgo all
investing and in lie of that they have
this
tremendous emotion and psychological
focus on singular goal of becoming
debt-free and then you stay out of debt
for the rest of your life you not only
get the match you get to max out all of
these retirements and it is ends up
being 15 years later the shortest path
to becoming a millionaire although the
short-term math of missing out on that
match for someone like you Austin or me
that was trained in nerd nerdville uh it
it it feels Blasphemous doesn't
it uh I understand what you're saying I
I feel like I'm stepping over dimes to
pick up pennies
almost when you take the match you are
yeah that I I get what you're saying
it's better to direct my Approach
towards one thing as opposed to try and
spread my Avenue out and which hasn't
worked for the past however many years
I've been going at this yeah let me give
you another example because it's a great
discussion for everyone to listen in on
this conversation because this comes up
a lot and because it there's a real it's
a real valid question and a valid
discussion but here's the other thing if
you don't get out of
debt and you don't change your mindset
about debt and you languish in Consumer
Debt for 10 years because simultaneously
you're trying to invest then what you've
done is you've completely
disabled the wealth building mechanism
and so by simply increasing the
probability of becoming and staying debt
free by shortening the
term you've increased the probability of
wealth dramatically you in other words
you can't half but do the get out of
debt and half butt do the investing
thing at the same time and ever get this
right yeah you never get clear of it
that's what ends up happening and so
it's a but it's but it man I get tripped
up on the math thing it here here's
another the the de snowball versus I was
on a h a podcast the other day with a
young lady in our space Erica very smart
lady and she used the debt Avalanche to
pay off she's a lawyer pay off her law
school debt and she was talking to me
about that I said yeah but you're a
highly disciplined valid dictorian
law student okay you you know you're an
unusual human being most of us are
normal human beings we have to see the
feedback loop of getting the little one
paid off and sensing some success and
traction which keeps me plugged in the
psychological feedback loop supersedes
the math change and here's the thing the
probability of completing the dead
Avalanche is one tenth yeah the
snowball yes in other words nine out of
10 people that start the that snowball
complete it one out of 10 on the avalan
completed or whatever the number is but
the the completion probability is not
figured into the stupid math equation
when someone says oh you should pay off
the highest interest rate first I use
the dead Avalanche which means you've
been on Tik tock not in reality that's
what that means and so you know again
Behavior trumps math when you do it on
the short term because our behaviors are
what caused the debt in the first place
yeah I agree I mean when I look at it I
think about it if you look at it as like
a football field right and let's say
de's in the end zone if you run straight
you're getting there faster but if you
zigzag a yard here and then zigzag a
yard there and then I'm going to put
five over here on this one and it takes
you forever forever to get to the end
zone that's exactly right yeah running
is run it straight up the middle all the
way you know and and take the yardage
you can get and then take then play the
next play then play the next play just
straight down the middle run it up the
gut run it up the gut that's what
exactly we're talking about um but the
other thing that we don't even us math
nerds mhm because this I I you know I've
been teaching it based on behavior for
25 almost 30 years so I I understand it
I believe it and I've got 10 million
people that have done it so I've got the
proof text that I'm right yeah you know
but but it's still messes with my brain
that's funny it didn't I'll be honest
with you that was the one thing that
didn't mess with my brain much you're
you you came out of the music background
the artist background you just went this
is how to do it do it yeah that's that
is true there's one way to play that
song yeah not two ways yeah I mean it's
not that song If you play it two ways
it's a different song that is true you
know I mean yeah and so this this is but
the math thing is uh you cannot and it's
the mistake that the financial world has
made MH all of the financial planning
world and all of the investing world and
all of the insurance World they try to
do everything based exclusively on math
in a behavior-based world yeah they
forget about mindset they forget about
behavi if we were only doing math no one
would credit card debt facts cuz it's
mathematically absurd if we were only
doing math no one would borrow $250,000
to get a degree in left-handed puppetry
Come On Dave I know only doing math but
this is not about math no one would go
into debt to go to a college campus
because they have a good football team
isn't that funny Dave how the math
matters until it doesn't matter right
when we don't want it to matter cuz we
get something it doesn't matter but then
when it's like like wait if it's if we
were doing math we wouldn't buy a car
that has a toxic plastic smell in it
called new car smell and watch the
depreciation happen when we drive it off
the lot that's right when you hear that
sound when you go off the lot bloom
bloom when you break the curb that was
the sound of $10,000 leaving your net
worth you know I mean but if we were
doing math we would never do that no but
we smell the toxic smell and go oh my
God this is wonderful smell the Le no
it's not leather it's it's carcinogens
you're getting cancer right now I'm just
oh my God unbelievable but yeah I mean
if we were doing math we wouldn't do
almost anything that we stupid human
beings do out there Austin that was a
great question you're you're awesome
thank you for asking that question but
the answer is don't solve a
behavior-based problem with a math-based
solution ding ding this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for joining us America Jade
washaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today I'm Dave Ramsey your host this is
a show where we talk about your
life oh your
life right in front of you
and we unpack all of it and we're
generally really nice about it I tell
you even if we're tough it's just
because we love you that's right and we
want you to Win Ben is with us Ben is in
Meridian Mississippi hi Ben welcome to
the ramsy show hello thanks for taking
my call sure what's
up so as of this time next week we will
be baby six or baby step six
complete you baby step seven is what
that means right wait a minute wait a
minute let stop he to just Breeze
you finished baby step 6 next week you
mean baby step seven you got your house
paid off we will pay it off next Tuesday
or Wednesday when Mr Schwab gives us our
money hey well come on Mr Schwab here we
go baby love it congratulations Ben how
much is the house
worth uh worth hopefully about 450 cool
how much in your retirement
accounts uh about 401k and then pulling
some of these investments in a big
savings account to pay it off all right
good for you all right how's that
feel uh palms are sweaty just thinking
about it you're going to love it if you
hate it you can go get you another
mortgage but you'll be all right I love
it man all right how can we help you
today we also have other money set aside
for sinking fun our house is 15 years
old we expect things like hbac water
heaters things like that to come is that
simple savings account type money or is
that investment money I would not put
that as investment money I think the
idea when you know you have things
coming up and you want to do syncing
funds that's separate even from your you
know emergency fund that's separate yeah
you can use the every dollar app to
create a breakdown of the syncing funds
for instance let's say you had an
emergency fund and then you had a high
yield savings account that you dump all
the syncing funds into all right and you
say the every dollar app will keep up
with okay there's $10,000 in there 4,000
is for air conditioner future um 1,000
is for Christmas uh you know and so on
to where the Thousand the $10,000 none
of it is vague it all has a name in that
one high yield savings account it's you
can break it down the every dollar app
right that's how you do that's right yep
you do it as funds the only time I would
think about something that's investable
is if it was years and years down the
line like maybe you have this dream of
renovating a room in your house and you
know it's five or six or seven years
down the line something like that yeah
or Ben I'll tell you when I did it in
addition to that okay I'm G Talk syncing
this is not a syncing fund this was just
extra investing and I was what I was
doing was I was saving to buy my first
rental with cash after we went broke and
had a house that was paid off so I just
started throwing that in an S&P 500
Index Fund and it would just sit there
andur until there was enough to buy a
rental and then I would throw all the
rental income net of expenses and any
other money I could find into an index
fund until I had enough money to buy
another rental and then every time I did
that I had more rental income going into
there so it pretty quick those houses
started buy another house
but uh uh and rental properties started
buying other rental properties but
that's the only time I did it other than
that just a high yield savings for stuff
like air conditioner roof replacement
Christmas next car uh that kind of stuff
I I would just use a high yield savings
separate from your emergency fund but
you can keep it named inside of every
dollar broken down yeah that's a really
good differential and I think Dave you
and I were on the show a couple of days
back and we talked about that your
emergency fund like if you want to have
some savings like you know uh sinking
fund type stuff that is totally separate
from your emergency fund your emergency
fund is only for actual emergencies and
I would not I keep same yeah I would not
put those in the same uh savings account
no because otherwise a bass boat will
turn into an emergency oh yeah you know
it's like you know and who says it's not
but it is but you know it's like of
course it
is I need a larger motor those bass keep
out running me yeah that's it so they're
fast Little Critters but um so yeah that
that that's the thing and you know I but
you look down and you go hey the boat I
was thinking about I had $110,000 save
for I or $25,000 I really want to buy
$5,000 more and reach over and pull it
out of the emergency fund without even
half thinking because but because it's
not in the same account it makes it hard
to do that it'll keep your butt from
doing it that's right it sure will cuz
my wife will amputate my hand if I reach
towards that account I call that uh you
know I call that Uncle Boo Boo Uncle boo
boo yeah that's the we all have an uncle
who convinces us to make the worst
possible financial decisions the dumb
the dumb little guy sitting on your
shoulder yeah like the little devil on
your shoulder Uncle boo boo yeah he'll
He he'll look at that money together and
say oh that looks like you have enough
money to go to my wedding in the
Caribbean next thing you
know this sounds like this happened Jay
did that really I know look that that
sound like that really happened just
then I sensed that you went to a
Caribbean wedding at some point that you
wished you hadn't ice I saw that Uncle
Boo Boo Uncle boooo is a persuasive
sales guy I didn't know him before but I
think I know him he sells whole life
insurance he only buys new cars cuz he
thinks they're good Investments own a
Payday lender that's
right what a jerk James is in Chesapeake
Virginia hi James how are you I'm doing
good how about you better than I deserve
what's up
yeah so let me give you a little rundown
I'm a I'm 19 years old I'm electrician
and I make just over $40,000 a year cool
and of course drive a company vehicle
with that as well very good um I've had
some I guess a couple people but one in
particular mention about credit cards I
don't have a credit card don't intend on
getting one and I guess I should say
won't get one
but
um with the credit cards I've had
somebody say that they when they use
them they're like a fraud protection not
because you need to cash back or for the
actual because you don't have money and
you've got to pay it in advance or and
you don't have the money now but you
could pay it at the end of the month
what is the fraud protection or why is
it I guess okay to use a credit card
because of the fraud protection there's
a lot of there's a lot of lies out there
that have been spread about this by
people who love credit cards James
so you can look it up for yourself it's
not hard if you pull up Visa and
Mastercards fraud protection on their
website both of them use this language
okay you have a zero
liability in the event of fraud for
credit card use is fraud visa and
MasterCard no MasterCard product no Visa
product of any kind credit card or debit
card allows someone to misuse your
number and the bank charge you for it so
if there's online fraud if someone
steals your number if someone steals
your card and uses it you are not liable
you have a zero liability with a debit
card or a credit card with visa and you
can look it up on their website it's it
has big old big old capital letters zero
liability policy on their agreement
their card holder agreement so the idea
that a credit card has more fraud
protection than a debit card is simply
not true it's someone that doesn't know
what they're talking
about okay you can look it up it's not
it's really just put zero fraud
protection on debit card debit it's
right there it pops up anywhere and
Google will put it right in your face so
it's not it's not even hard to research
this and find it out but people hear
some duber talking about I get airline
miles and I get fraud protection and no
one should ever recommend the debit card
cuz it doesn't have fraud protection and
they heard some on Tik Tok say
that and so they believe the on
Tik Tok instead of actually looking up
the credit card agreement or the debit
card agreement it's and it's it's
Universal in order for it to have the
little Mastercard or VISA symbol on the
front of it whether it be a credit card
or a debit card the in the issuing bank
has to abide by the agreement with visa
and MasterCard and provide a zero
liability in the event of fraud there
you have it ding ding
done yeah it's over I've never had a
problem using a debit card and if
somebody did for I've never ever had a
problem with them giving my money back
I've never even had I mean I it get it
gets shut down with the stupid fraud
algorithms but so the credit cards yeah
at this point yeah call did you make
this charge yes I was in Mexico okay but
oh my God you know like I have to call
and tell my we have to call notify our
bank if we're leaving the country cuz
they immediately assume someone stole
our number right yeah so but that's just
that's the world we live in cuz there's
frosters everywhere uh but that but
either way you're protected in the event
someone actually did use it we had
actually did have somebody hit my card
come to think of it and the bank just
put the money back instantly that's
right but um they can wait 2 or 3 days
but they generally don't yeah this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
our scripture of today Proverbs 1311
dishonest money money dwindles away but
whoever get gathers money little by
little makes it
grow H like investing in stuff oh there
you go Bob Hope said a bank is a place
that will lend you money if you can
prove that you don't need
it I miss people like Bob Hope oh I'm so
old I love it I love it wow all right
Cody is in Montgomery Alabama hi Cody
welcome to the Ramsey Show hello Dave
how are you better than I deserve what's
up so I'm a 2 Oney old college kid and
I'll be graduating this may with zero
debt way to go I've had the honor well I
have to pay credit to my parents they've
really helped me out with this and
they've seen the uh the damage that
student loans can do wow wonderful me
and my girlfriend have been together for
six years now and we're both in nursing
and we're projected to graduate together
in May and um we're expecting to make
120 to 140 our first year combined
you're not combined you're a girlfriend
well yeah that's to come though I plan
on getting married before all this is
over um okay like before graduation is
that what you're saying uh shortly after
okay good for you okay fun what a great
life my parents thank you my parents are
going to allow me to live at home and
save all this money so I can adjust to
this new job before I jump out and start
making a bunch of crazy decisions and um
my girlfriend she doesn't really want to
do that she wants to maybe stay at home
for six months I'd like to stay home for
a year and save all my money so I can
have an accurate down payment on a house
and I wanted to ask you um should I put
down larger than the 20% that you
recommend and put the excess in
Investments or I'm a little bit confused
are you getting married and the two of
you moving in with your
parents no so shortly after grad well
we're going to live at home separately I
mean she lives basically right down the
street from me the first year that's my
plan she so you're not getting married
right after graduation no it'll be
within that year though it'll be within
that year if the point of if the point
of waiting to get married is so that you
can do this house and down payment I
that wouldn't be a reason for me
no I don't you know what I mean I feel
like what you're trying to do is create
like this perfect scenar together six
freaking years you're going to go live
in your mother's basement to save money
to be one more year before you actually
marry the girl no not a chance dude
y'all go get married get you anart get
you an apartment this
summer get married in may start life in
an apartment start piling up money if it
takes you a year or two buy a house
you're going to be making you're both
nurses oh my gosh it's a wonderful
career field you can work like you know
as much as you want to work save up
money don't worry about a house you can
buy a house after a year buy a house
after two years I don't care you're
still going to be 25 years old be a
homeowner and be debt free everything
but the house I know that's right you'll
be very smart and very married
I appreciate it and I have one more
question um we are we're both uh we love
the idea of being a travel nurse and
we'd like to do that after about three
years of experience so three years after
graduation we're going to try to go all
over the country and do that for about
two to three years should I be renting
or should I buy a house before I leave
and try to rent it out I if if I knew
that I was wanting to be a travel nurse
and travel all around the world even
more reason to just get an apartment and
hang out there until you're ready to
settle yeah I wouldn't buy while you're
traveling if you're going to travel for
3 years why don't you do that early why
do you have to wait you have to have an
experience to do that yeah the field
usually requires one to two years some
of the rules have changed with coid but
that's still what we're yeah with the
nursing shortage after the fouchy
pandemic that's a
thing yeah that's real I mean the nurses
it was man we had some nurses coming in
here we had one lady you remember that
lady I don't remember if you were on the
a with me or who was did a debt-free
scream was a travel nurse and she made
like I mean Co year oh yeah chick made
like 550 Grand in one year she worked
all the OT and they were paying like
triple time because I mean wow they cuz
you guys I mean you were the you were
the hot commodity then and you are still
cuz there's now a shortage cuz so many
people left over uh uh you know vaccine
requirements mask requirements other
things they left the industry they got
out of it and so now there's a shortage
and now the hospitals have this weird D
they forgot that they ran all their
talent off and um now they're oh God we
were stupid who knew but um yeah we were
requiring everyone to be vaccinated and
people didn't want to do it and so we
fired them oh yeah that's us yeah and
um wow okay yeah so I if you can go on
the road the sooner you can go on the
road and make bank I would call that
your early Adventure two of you get
married may pass your bars and go on the
road and go make three or 400 between
the two of you not 120 between the two
of you that beats Mama's basement all
day ding ding you know got to tell you
beating Mama's basement is a low bar
though hey it comes with free meals that
that is still a low bar love Mom love
you Mama love you mama not coming all
right Mama and them that's a thing right
there right Tracy is with us in Portland
Oregon hi Tracy welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey Dave and Jade it's so good to
talk to you both you too what's up I
need some thank you I need some more sha
ranid math magic please let's go we give
it a shot okay so here's my background
um in April of 2022 I purchased a home
in New Mexico however due to medical
reasons I had to return to Oregon and
I'll be staying here so as of now the
home is with a property management
business and it's currently rented
shortterm and um so here's the numbers I
have for you I purchased it for 300
180,000 was 120 down at 4.9% in April of
last year it's currently valued just
looking online at Zillow for 60,000 less
than what I paid for it already ah Zill
is not Dependable I know what city are
you in I get it uh Alam mordo which is
out in the middle of nowhere but there
is a military base nearby I put uh 50k
in upgrades and my question is should I
sell it or leave it as a rental and
hopes that it continues to be occupied
or sell it at a really big loss and it
rents for two uh 2500 a month my
mortgage is700 a month so with the
property management fee that gives me
about 550 I'm not looking to make money
I just want to break even but it doesn't
look like I don't know what to do
yeah uh number one I want to get better
facts so what I would do is go to
ramseys solutions.com and click on the
Ramsey trusted real estate agents the
endorsed local providers have one of
them go do a comparative market analysis
a CMA on it which is basically a realtor
appraisal and let's find out what the
house is really worth and find out find
out if the blood bath you think you have
is really
real because that changes everything I
mean you're you think you're going to
lose 50,000 turns out you're going to
lose 5,000 it changes the discussion
right right and so yeah 5,000 I'm out of
here
uh make 5,000 I'm out of here okay but
generally speaking Nationwide houses
have not dropped that much yeah what do
we think would have if this is true what
do we think would have caused that other
than you overpaying initially she got in
she got in the fever and
overpaid you got in the tail I don't
know I mean maybe I did maybe I did
because I sold my house here in Portland
to move down there and made a killing so
I mean people were doing the same thing
on that end is they were
getting what they could for the houses
and there wasn't much of a market so I
had to buy a house at the time yeah so I
didn't buy it where it it was valued it
appraised it that I had to go through
the VA so it appraised it that so but
just the market has fallen there and
it's it's possible that a unique micro
Market the the macro Market Nationwide
has not dropped but the uh some of the
individual markets have and some of the
individual markets have increased still
substantially because there's still
shortage of housing
so um it's possible that but I I would
want to do something more than Zillow to
make the decision I'd want solid info Z
get a good Ramsey real estate agent a
good Ramsey trusted real estate agent to
go out there and walk you through this
and they'll tell you you know I think if
you'll hold on six months is Market a
rebound based on things that are H
happening in that local economy I don't
know no I definitely wouldn't listen to
Zillow but um well I mean not as my sole
arbitrator I mean it might be accurate
sometimes it is but it's just not it
they use algorithms they're not using
actual CMAs and so it's not slamming
Zillow it's just a matter of you know
it's a mass produced thing so anyway
look at that and then decide if you can
stomach the loss or not and if you want
to there's not a wrong answer unless
unless it's putting you in a pinch today
this is the Ramsey Show we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the of Peace
Christ
[Music]
Jesus hey what's up guys it's Jade look
if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the ramsy baby steps
go to ramseys solutions.com and click
the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation that's
ramseys solutions.com and click get
[Music]
started